et cette guerre en Ukraine débutée il y
a une semaine maintenant elle provoque
bien sûr un exode massif de la
population selon les Nations Unies un
million de personnes sont déplacées à
l'intérieur du pays au moins 836000
autres ont duel passer les frontières
pour fuir les combats au moins 450000
sont en Pologne ou Charles Michel le
président du Conseil européen a
rencontré ce matin vous le voyez le
Premier ministre polonais de la
frontière 7 frontière Emmanuel Chaze s'y
trouve justement pour France 24 bonjour
Emmanuel sur place d'importants efforts
sont faits par les autorités polonaises
pour finalement donner un peu d'aide à
ses Ukrainiens qui arrivent il faut le
dire par milliers
ouais tout à fait c'est une aide
absolument sans précédent une aide
absolument en colossale qui est mise en
place non seulement par le gouvernement
polonais mais également par la
population polonaise alors là où je me
trouve à rébéné à la frontière au poste
frontière de rébéné vous voyez une aide
humanitaire qui s'organise alors elle
est elle est encore peu importante ici
mais les gens qui arrivent ont de quoi
manger de quoi boire et le gouvernement
a mis en place un système de bus qui
récupère ceux des réfugiés qui sont
arrivés à pied et qui les emmène dans
les dans les hébergements d'urgence des
hébergements d'urgence qui se trouve
dans des écoles qui ont été
réquisitionnés vous voyez derrière moi
également beaucoup de voitures alors ces
voitures se sont celles d'ukrainien qui
habite en Pologne ou tout simplement de
Polonais qui ont de la famille en
Ukraine des amis en Ukraine et c'est un
balai incessant de voiture de personnes
qui viennent récupérer leurs proches qui
viennent récupérer leur famille ils
attendent parfois pendant des jours
parce que certaines personnes ont été
sur la route à la frontière pendant plus
de 4 jours j'ai parlé à des gens qui
habitent dans la ville de Liège qui se
trouve à seulement 70 km du côté
ukrainien et bien ils ont passé 4 jours
dans les bouchons une ligne de 60 km de
bouchon avant d'arriver à la à la
frontière mais une aide colossa qui
s'organise ici il y a eu aussi beaucoup
de témoignages de résident étranger en
Ukraine qui évidemment eux aussi tente
de fuir le conflit qui ont évoqué
notamment le fait qu'il partait en
dernier dans ses budget pourtant plus
parler avec des Angolais avec des
Congolais avec des Vietnamiens hier ils
sont ici ils sont pris en charge par des
représentants de leur ambassade la
Pologne a assuré que tous avaient le
droit de passer la frontière ceux des
non-ukrainiens qui arriverait par cette
frontière bénéficie d'un permis de
séjour de 15 jours
bonjour après lesquels ils doivent être
rapatrier dans leur pays d'origine
Emmanuel vous avez face à vous des
Ukrainiens éreintés vous l'avez bien
compris que vous raconte-t-il il y a
aussi vous nous la raconterez après
c'est
ukrainien qui repartent dans leur pays
parfois pour se battre
que dans le sang suprême Pologne je vois
arriver des gens en permanence qui sont
complètement effondré par ce qui se
passe des personnes âgées notamment qui
ont traversé le pays qui a qui ont dû
tout laisser derrière eux qui viennent
parfois avec leurs petits-enfants et
leur fille mais leur fils sont restés au
pays se battre donc c'est extrêmement
éprouvant pour eux et comme vous l'avez
dit également énormément d'ukrainien
j'ai pu parler à certains d'entre eux de
jeunes Ukrainiens qui repartent dans
l'autre direction pour défendre leur
pays hier je parlais avec un groupe
d'entre eux à peine âgé d'une vingtaine
d'années qui habitent en Pologne ils
habitent en Pologne ils veulent
retourner dans leur pays pour se battre
ils ont pris quelques jours pour
s'équiper pour pour avoir des des habits
militaires qui leur permettent également
de faire face au froid il fait très
froid ici il y a des températures en
dessous de 2-0 ils sont partis ils
savent très bien qu'il qu'il risque leur
vie mais ils veulent défendre leur
de toute la RAM et c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment qu'on ressent ici
auprès de la population
Ukraine c'est une Ukrainienne pardon
c'est une population extrêmement fière
extrêmement courageuse et que ça soit du
côté des réfugiés ou du côté de ceux qui
vont se battre on le ressent à chaque
instant en parlant avec eux merci
beaucoup Emmanuel